pues llegó el momento ya de repasar la
economía aquí en directo América edición
nocturna ya tenemos para ello nuestro
compañero Jorge Hurtado aquí en el
estudio Jorge bienvenido vamos a hablar
de la reserva Federal de Estados Unidos
que como os esperaba volvió a subir los
tipos de interés así que bueno el
aumento de hoy fue de 25 puntos básicos
y ahora el precio del dinero queda entre
el rango del 4,5% el 4,75 por ciento se
trata Rodrigo del octavo ascenso
consecutivo desde que inició el
endurecimiento de la política monetaria
para tratar de frenar la inflación el
movimiento de hoy es una reducción del
ritmo de aumento de los tipos Antes hubo
un aumento de medio punto y otros cuatro
aumentos de 75 puntos básicos el
presidente de la reserva Federal de
Estados Unidos anticipó que el Banco
Central llevará a cabo Durante los
próximos meses más aumentos de los tipos
de interés el mercado Espera que sean
menos agresivos El Banco Central de la
economía más grande del mundo busca
reducir la inflación y al 2% Desde que
la inflación alcanzó su máximo en junio
pasado del 9,1% anual ha caído hasta el
6,5 Y en diciembre bajó por sexto mes
consecutivo dato que según los analistas
es señal de que la subida de los tipos
de interés están comenzando a hacer
efecto en la economía estadounidense
escuchemos si parte del discurso de jump
la inflación se mantiene muy por encima
de Nuestro objetivo a largo plazo del 2%
Durante los 12 meses que finalizaron en
diciembre los precios subieron un 5% y
excluyendo las volátiles categorías de
alimentos y energía los precios de la
inflación subyacente subieron un
4,4%, los datos de inflación recibidos
en los últimos tres meses muestran una
reducción del Ritmo mensual de aumentos
Y aunque la evolución reciente es
alentadora necesitaremos muchas más
evidencias Para estar seguros de que la
inflación se encuentra en una Senda
descendente sostenida
Jorge seguimos en Estados Unidos Porque
si este aumento era esperado lo que sí
que nos esperaba tanto era el aumento de
las ofertas de empleo en diciembre y
esto pese al aumento de los tipos de
interés que mencionábamos anteriormente
en diciembre se registraron 1,9 ofertas
de empleo por cada desempleado según
mostró el informe mensual del
departamento del trabajo muchos
analistas se atreven a decir que esta
podría ser la primera recesión de la
historia sin pérdida significativas del
empleo las ofertas de empleo aumentaron
en 572.000 hasta un máximo de cinco
meses de 11 millones otros 409 mil
puestos de trabajo quedaron sin cubrir
en el sector de servicios de alojamiento
y alimentación el empleo en este sector
sigue por debajo de su nivel anterior a
la pandemia Jorge vamos ahora hasta
México que aumentó el recibo de remesas
bueno los envíos de dinero de mexicanos
en el extranjero crecieron un 13,4% más
que el mismo periodo de 2021 las remesas
a México alcanzaron retórica de
58.497 millones de dólares en 2022 y
suma ya 32 meses consecutivos al alza en
recepción de remesas las remesas ya son
un Pilar de la economía mexicana ayer el
Instituto Nacional de geografía
estadísticas dio a conocer que la
economía mexicana creció un 3% en 2022
los mexicanos que laboran en el exterior
principalmente en Estados Unidos envían
en promedio 390 dólares al mes en
Estados Unidos hay 12 millones de
migrantes mexicanos del total de remesas
El 95% provienen de ahí en segundo lugar
se ubica Canadá y de tercero Ecuador
interesante es esos datos Jorge nos
vamos hasta Europa porque la comisión
europea presentó hoy un plan destinado a
la mayor fabricación al aumento de la
producción de tecnologías y energías
limpias dentro de la Unión Europea Así
es bueno van a debatir la próxima semana
Cómo responder a Estados Unidos y
también a China sin fragmentar el
mercado único será en una Cumbre
extraordinaria en la que los jefes de
estado y gobierno de los 27 discutirán
Cómo responder a la ira la nueva
legislación norteamericana que da ayudas
millonarias a sus empresas verdes pero
que según Europa castiga a sus empresas
el bloque el bloque quiere que
Washington del mismo trato que Estados
Unidos da a Canadá y a México a nivel
comercial para entrar en esta carrera
europea Europa necesita más plantas
turbinas chips paneles inversión en
hidrógeno así como cientos de millones
de euros para ejecutar el proyecto
Estados Unidos ya se adelantó
movilizando casi medio billón de dólares
en crédito Fiscales deducciones y ayudas
directas a esta industria pues deberá
acelerar la Unión Europea si quiere
cumplir sus plazos de neutralidad de
carbono nos vamos hasta Nigeria donde se
preparan para elecciones presidenciales
y todo ello en medio de una enorme
escasez de combustible Rodrigo y es que
de norte a sur en ese país de unos 215
millones de habitantes se enfrenta a una
combinación de problemas escasez
gasolina y caos en los bancos por un
nuevo cambio de Divisas además de la
falta de agua y electricidad el próximo
mes Nigeria celebrará elecciones
presidenciales en la que el presidente
muhammadú bujari dejará el cargo tras
los dos mandatos que les permite la
Constitución Aunque en Nigeria es uno de
los mayores productores de crudo de
África casi no tiene capacidad de
refinado y debe importar su combustible
desde Europa y otros lugares conoce como
siempre Muchas gracias por este repaso
económico vamos ya con el debate de
Santiago López
[Música]